it's a true story set in 1930 and it's
about the largest oil found in the
history of the world true story it was
about two con Men played by myself and
there's John ratzenberger just the other
side of me there and next to Lou aluga
said and they would go through Oklahoma
and Texas wooing widows out of their
money on fake oil wells they would sell
500 of the shares declare dry hold going
to the next city they get down to Texas
in the Kilgore area they strike oil by
accident largest oil fine in the history
of the world I'm not giving anything
away because it's miracle in East Texas
there's other little miracles happen
along the way but it's it's one best
romantic comedy best faith film family
film uh the judge's favorite it's an
amazing movie we've only got two days
it's a fathom movie and fathom gets
independent movies out there when 750
screens but we need people if you buy
tickets right now to sell this sucker
out we'll get more dates it's a PG film
you can take your six-year-old and I saw
that it's got the pay it forward method
too if you want to buy tickets for us
it's a wonderful true story